the next award is for a special
achievement for visual effects that
presented a man who is a special visual
effect himself a wild and crazy guy
Steve Martin
thank you very much
I'm Steve Martin I'm here to present the
award for special visual effects
I think you can tell but my expression
that it was kind of a compromise for me
to come down here tonight because I was
nominated last year in the category of
Best live action short and when I lost
that award I made a vow never to show my
face around here again
so this is kind of the compromise deal
I'm back the special achievement award
for visual effects in Superman goes to
dennis coop roy field derrick nettings
colin Chilvers Zorin parsec and less
bowie
one of me
ladies and gentlemen on behalf of my
colleagues and myself I'd like to thank
the Board of Governors of the Academy
for these magnificent awards and sadly
our other associate Liz Bay recently
passed away as a great loss to us and
the industry we'd like to thank our
producer Richard Donner a friend and
director and particularly our British
cruise who without whose support we
wouldn't be here this evening and
finally a thank you to Margot Kidder and
Christopher Reeve what a super man thank
you
I'm kind of glad we changed our mind
about having Steve Martin give the award
to Lord Olivier in case you're wondering
and many people don't know this how
Superman met Lois Lane has never been
divulged but he was getting undressed in
a phone booth when he saw scribbled on
the wall call Lois for a super night and
here tonight is Superman Christopher
Reeve and his favorite girl reporter
Margot Kidder
boy there sure were some incredible
special effects and Superman worker
never wait a minute Margo you know not
everything in the film was a trick Chris
it was just a movie Chris oh yeah
hmm excuse me aha
the winner is Chris Chris do do you mind
if we read the nominees first with it oh
we got to read oh sorry
if you insist okay now for Oh
outstanding achievement in sound the
nominees this year our Tech's Rudd LOF
Joel fine curly thir well and Willie
Burton for the Buddy Holly story Johnny
K Wilkinson Robert W glass jr. and John
T writes four days of heaven remaining
credits and controversy it's important
in leading the coffee Erin Rochin and
Darrin night for the deer hunter Robert
Knudsen Robert E glass Jack MacDougall
and Jack Solomon for Hooper Gordon
McCallum Graham hearthstone Nikolas from
Missouri hey Android Charmin for a super
super or something and the winner is
winners are Richard Portman William
McCauley Erin routes in a daring night
for the jr. motor
been a long time coming I have to thank
Michael Cimino who I love a fine group
of technicians at metro-goldwyn-mayer
studios and the just a wonderful
business to be in the C honor of my life
thank you very much pardon me a special
thanks to my coach amino James J clinger
Frank rial and many many fine
technicians into the Academy thank you
I would also like to thank my coach
Amina for his creative suggestions and
inspiration during the mix of The Deer
Hunter I'd like to thank the MGM sound
and projection personnel for all their
help and I'd like to thank all the
members of the Academy for making my
greatest aspiration in reality thank you
I'd also like to thank Michael Jimmie
know and Don Bolger and my wife for
staying with me in the jungles of
Thailand to shoot this picture and all
the members of the Academy thank you all
very much